just how many millions will Billy Bush
get to walk away from the Today Show but
the auditions begin for his replacement
the one and only Harry Connick jr. is
here come on Harry Connick jr. stepped
into the turmoil at the Today show this
morning filling in for the embattled
Billy Bush showing off his dance moves
and charming the co-host hey I was so
excited when I heard that I was invited
to the show cuz I'm a big fan of the
show I think it's absolutely fair to
look at this as sort of an open audition
a little bit like what you saw with
Kelly's show in the morning there I
think you're seeing people pitching
because they literally have to keep the
show on the air and at the same time I
think they're saying how's the chemistry
it's been more than a week now since
Bush was suspended from the Today Show
after this video leaked showing Bush and
Donald Trump making rude comments late
Friday Bush's lawyer released this
statement quote there are news reports
that a 10 million dollar settlement has
been reached between Billy Bush and NBC
that report is false there is no 10
million dollar agreement and that amount
has not been discussed negotiations are
ongoing between the parties in talking
the folks at NBC and elsewhere it's
pretty clear that the negotiations are
taking longer than NBC expected and
certainly longer than we see it hoped
meanwhile SNL was all in this weekend
setting its sights on bush and the Trump
tape you can't talk like that why not
Billy Bush said bad things and my mom
says he might get 10 million dollars and
it's not just SNL right now there's a
bush backlash on Twitter it all started
when a comedian falsely tweeted that
Bush was going to donate his NBC
settlement to women's organizations that
sparked the trending hashtag thanks
Billy and a series of me I think this is
the you know the magic and appeal of
social media as a counterbalance to fame
and celebrity I think he gets to decide
what he does with that money I think
he's gonna have to figure out a way to
make amends with her symbolic financial
in some other way